president Trump touts Bible literacy
bills that seek to teach students about
the most influential book in the history
of the world naturally the left is up in
arms then the FBI arrests 66 year-old
foppish GOP operative Roger stone
finally our streets are safe 2020 gets
even Wilder for Democrats Texas uncovers
massive voter fraud and pop culture
admits that unborn babies are unborn
babies that's pretty good I'm Michael
Nolan this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to today I love this
Bible literacy tweet president from
tweeted it out he said that we're gonna
get Bible literacy in schools
if political reforms can instill Bible
literacy in American students that will
be the most beneficial and consequential
political political reform rather of my
entire lifetime we'll get to that in a
second first we got to talk about stone
and before that we got to make a low
money honey with 1-800 flowers here is a
relationship tip it is not going to feel
like Valentine's Day unless there is a
surprise bouquet of roses involved and
this gentleman you know if you really
want it to feel like Valentine's Day and
you forget to get your little honey
flowers it we it will not feel like
Valentine's Day I'm sorry to tell you
you should get the biggest and brightest
roses at 1-800 flowers dot-com right now
when you order early 1-800 flowers has
amazing deals on vibrant and romantic
Valentine's rose bouquets arrangements
and more starting at just $29.99 do it
now guys you don't want to find yourself
three hours before Valentine's Day
scrambling one year I had to go down the
street to a grocery store I spent 90
bucks on pretty sad looking flowers
don't do it call 1-800 flowers or go to
1-800 flowers calm rather today it's a
it's a terrific service there what if
roses from 1-800 flowers are picked at
their peak they're shipped overnight to
ensure freshness and her amazement
starting at $29.99 you can't beat it
let 1-800 flowers handle this for you
don't settle for anything less than the
Rose Authority 1-800 flowers calm to
order valentines bouquets arrangements
and more restarting at $29.99 go to
1-800 flowers dot-com click the radio
icon and enter code cofee facio v fe fe
a natural aphrodisiac
kofi fay you will love it order today
and say that 1-800 flowers comm code
Coface EO VF e fe before we get to bible
literacy i want to talk about the arrest
of Roger stone you probably saw this CNN
had footage of this in the middle of the
night 29 FBI agents came in 17 vehicles
lights flashing automatic weapons in tow
to kick in the door
and arrests a 66 year old political
operative named Roger stone he's this
foppish political operative he has a
tattoo of Richard Nixon on his back he
has said for months now that if Muller
wants him he's happy to turn himself in
and cooperate but no the the FBI
investigation had to kick in his door
and somehow CNN found out about it how'd
they find out about it ahead of time I
don't know they're just they're just
such good reporters there that must that
must be the reason so they kick him in
they arrest him they bring Roger stone
hauled him down to the clink and then a
couple hours later he's released on
$250,000 bond he gives this great press
conference he walks out because he's a
big fan of Richard Nixon he walks out
with the two v of signs up in the air
just like Richard Nixon he's got the V
up there side note the hippies took over
the V sign and made it the peace Nick
sign the V sign is great Churchill used
it Nixon used it I think we need to
reclaim it a Roger stone is reclaiming
it he went out and he gave this press
conference
this is a line that he's used a lot I've
heard it it's a kind of common knowledge
in politics the only thing worse than
being talked about is not being talked
about and by the way this is why I think
he actually might get off just fine in
this whole thing I think Roger stones
dishonesty might save him when he
emerged and gave this press conference
he looked as happy as I've ever seen the
guy Roger stone for those who don't know
him he's an old-time political adviser
to Donald Trump not exactly necessarily
on presidential politics it looks like
he got kicked off that Trump
presidential campaign pretty early but
he helped him out with local lobbying
stuff it stoned us a lot of ballot
propositions he writes books he goes on
speaking tours and as a lot of people
have observed he he brags about doing a
lot of things that he most likely didn't
do so if they think they're gonna get
him on colluding with Russia or talking
to WikiLeaks or whatever there's a good
chance he bragged about doing that but
he didn't actually do it stone goes on
[Music]
elaboration or any other illegal act in
connection with the 2016 campaign I am
mostly accused of making false
statements during my testimony for the
House Intelligence Committee that is
incorrect immaterial and without intent
so stone has been waiting to be indicted
for a while now I get a real kick out of
this guy especially I'm from New York
he's spends a lot of time in New York
has been based out of New York
I get a real kick out of him in politics
because he's a total showman he wears
crazy clothing and he got into a bit of
hot water in 1996 he was on the dole for
president campaign and it came out that
he had run a sex ad in some swingers
magazine trying to pick up different
people to go on swinging threesomes
whatever he has always been libertarian
he's now a member of the libertarian
party and he calls himself a libertine I
mean he comes from that libertine wing
of the Republicans pgo work wrote a
famous essay called republican party
reptile had to drive fast on drugs while
getting your win lang squeezed and not
spill your drink Roger stone comes from
that side of the Republican Party and I
you know I get a kick out of him
but I think this is where he comes out
and says I'm not guilty the only crime
that they're accusing me of is lying to
Congress because he said that he
telephoned somebody when in fact he
might have emailed to that person and
they've got him now and they're gonna
try to squeeze him on this but he said
that's immaterial and that was done
without intent so he'll he'll very
possibly get off on that and they're
they're trying to say that he colluded
with the Russians what a lot of this
comes down to is did Roger stone speak
directly to WikiLeaks did it was he in
contact with Julian Assange and did he
act as a conduit for the Trump campaign
to Julian Assange or the Russian
government or whatever the reason I
think he probably didn't maybe he did
he's been an operative and a lobbyist
for a long time but the reason I think
he probably didn't is because he brags
about doing things that he didn't do
so he there a few great profiles on him
usually profiles that he is instigating
and one of them in The New Yorker talks
about all these dirty tricks he said he
played his first dirty trick in the
third grade when he supported Kennedy
for president this was before he became
a conservative he supported Kennedy so
they had a mock election in class and he
told all the kids that Nixon wanted
school on Saturdays and Kennedy won in a
landslide and he's used disinformation
ever since so maybe that happened also
that's just a legendary story we've
heard this for years about various
presidential campaigns a lot of people
use it I wouldn't be surprised at all of
stone is just saying that to her self
aggrandizement he says he played a dirty
trick on the Nixon re-election campaign
he was a low-level staffer and he played
a dirty trick on a possible primary
opponent of Richard Nixon named Pete
McCluskey he says that he donated under
a pseudonym Jason Rainier to the young
socialists alliance in the name of Pete
McCluskey and then he sent the receipts
to the newspaper to make McCluskey look
like he was a left-wing stooge and
interloper trying to take over the
Republican Party or something did it
happen yeah maybe it did I don't know
possibly stone takes credit for the
Brooks Brothers riot down in Florida in
2000 this was when Al Gore wanted 50
million recounts of the ballots so that
he can cheat his way into the presidency
and there was a riot there was a big
demonstration of a lot of GOP operatives
they called it the Brooks Brothers riot
because it was all these buttoned up
conservatives and their nice fancy ties
and suits and a stone takes credit for
that there's a a GOP lawyer name's Brad
Blakeman who says that he was the one
who organized the Brooks Brothers riot
he was in the Winnebago he didn't see
Roger stone anywhere to be found there
Tucker Carlson in a documentary about
stone actually kind of backs that up he
says it's not so much what stone has
done but what stone has gotten you to
believe that he has done
that's a documentary made by a pal of
mine that I've actually worked with
called get me Roger stone he also takes
credit for taking down New York Democrat
Governor Eliot Spitzer Eliot Spitzer was
a dirty creep Democrat governor of New
York and he was caught using high
prostitutes and he had to resign Roger
stone after this all happened said that
he first found out about it in a dodgy
club in Miami from a Cole girl and then
he let the FBI know he sent the FBI a
letter and he came up with all these
lurid details the FBI says they never
got a letter from Roger stone we have no
idea if he actually talked to this call
girl but stone in his political
brilliance is able to insert himself
into the Spitzer takedown story if you
asked the regular average political
operative on the street they believe the
Roger stone took down Spitzer really the
FBI maintains this is part of a longtime
investigation into Eliot Spitzer and
stone didn't have anything to do with it
I bring all of this up because stone
says that he would he talked to
WikiLeaks he said he was in contact with
WikiLeaks he's now being accused of
telling Trump's senior campaign aides in
June and July of 2016 that WikiLeaks had
damaging documents on the Democrats
which might be true but everybody
already knew that WikiLeaks had those
documents in June and July of 2016 that
was already public knowledge at the time
so Roger stone is just telling people
what everyone already knew he said he
had spoken to WikiLeaks but what's the
evidence that he actually had because by
September 2017 he said he never did
speak to WikiLeaks and I tend to believe
that I tend to believe the latter part
because not because I think stone
wouldn't do it I just don't think he had
access and I think he was bragging about
it Donald Trump came out and said Roger
is always taking credit for things that
he didn't do and WikiLeaks has now come
out and said quote stone is playing
slovenly Democrat Alliance journalists
like a fiddle brilliantly inserting
himself as is his habit to raise his
public profile and market his books he
was pushed out of the Trump team a long
time ago for just this kind of
opportunism I don't mention this because
I don't like Roger stone or I have a
grudge against Roger stone or anything
like that I get a huge kick out of Roger
stone I really like him I think he does
pretty good work very often for the
conservative cause I'm saying this
because I think his best defense is his
dishonesty and I think that if they
really had him on colluding with
Vladimir Putin or something he couldn't
have given that press conference
he wouldn't have allowed himself to be
that open and that vulnerable he'd have
to be the stupidest political operative
on the face of the earth I think he is
as he has done throughout his entire
career playing the media like a fiddle
as WikiLeaks says and I I can't wait to
see the rest of it because again you see
the headlines Trump advisor indicted
they've got him that they've got him on
a procedural crime possibly lying to
Congress and even the evidence for that
is pretty slim what do they have the
other guys on George papadopolis Carter
page Paul Manafort it's all this
procedural stuff it all has to do with
the rush investigation itself and that's
the real story the real crimes that may
have been committed or by the people who
launched this rush investigation who
colluded with the Democrats who colluded
with the Clinton campaign and yes who
colluded with the Russians to assemble
the steel dossier on which this whole
charade has been based we'll see as time
goes on but this Russia thing really is
falling apart look no further than
Democrat Rep Eric Saul well speaking to
Margaret Hoover on her firing line show
he can't answer even basic questions
about his hysterical Russia claims at
what point you draw the line and not
accused the president United States
without any evidence of being an agent
of Russia
yeah he's betrayed our country and I
don't I don't say that lightly I worked
as a prosecutor for seven years and I
betraying the country by the way we want
evidence before you say that but you
said an agent of Russia
he works on their behalf he since he met
with Vladimir Putin in Helsinki in July
where he took the interpreters notes or
hasn't told any US official what they
discussed
he has taken us out of Syria which is a
top priority of Russia he sought to
diminish or pullout the u.s. from NATO
and he's easing sanctions on Vladimir
Putin's friends who are under
investigation have sanctions against
Russia
he has armed Ukraine he has killed 200
Russians in Syria I mean those aren't
the actions of an agent of Russia either
he signed I think you know but
grudgingly sanctions against Russia oh
it was begrudging he being li killed 200
Russians in Syria he'd be grudgingly
this is really sad Erick's whoa well
what is he
here what can he say and he's one of the
most articulate Democrats I've heard
talking about Russia and he's got
nothing
he just says things he says the talking
points and then you can easily shoot all
of them down and then they've got he
said well Trump yeah but he only did it
be grudgingly listen don't judge Trump
on his actions judge Trump on what I
think his intentions are
that's what Eric's wall well is saying
that's what the Democrats are saying you
can't judge Trump on what he actually
does you have to judge Trump on our
psychobabble interpretation of his
intentions it's ridiculous it just falls
apart and I think Roger stone probably
couldn't be happier the FBI got Paul man
afford on some serious shady dealings
not with regard to Trump not with regard
to the Russian collusion in 2016 or
anything like that
but they got him on some of his lobbying
from years ago and so you don't see Paul
Manafort smiling happy bubbly giving
press conferences Roger stone is a
different character and for people who
have been around political operations
you can see these two types of character
there are guys who actually work and
lurk in the shadows who perform really
nefarious operations for dictators
around the world and then there's guys
like Roger stone who are media figures
just think about it this way if you
wanted to be a real blackops kind of
political operator would you make
certain that everybody knows your name
if you wanted to be a real dark arts
political operator would you wear really
silly multicolored suits and go on TV
all the time probably not how many of
you had heard the name Paul Manafort
before he became prominent with the
Trump campaign none probably not very
many but how many had seen Roger stone
on TV in the newspaper giving an
interview hosting a big political stunt
press conference probably most of you
somebody else I forget who it was some
GOP figure was discussing Roger stone oh
no I'm sorry was Hank Sheinkopf who's a
great Democrat political operative but
truly one of the one of the greats and
he's a known stone for a long
and he said I always got the impression
with Roger that Roger was more focused
on his life than his work he was more
focused on how the work served his life
and his image then then how the image
served his work and I think that's
probably accurate so a good on him I
think he's probably gonna have the time
of his life here and there is no figure
better in conservative politics to make
a fool of the of the mainstream media
and this silly investigation probably
than Roger stone so good luck and if
they catch you having done shady things
I won't be surprised but if you catch
them with their pants down I'll be even
less surprised the really good news in
the cycle today has nothing to do with
the Russian investigation or even
political machinations President Trump
tweeted out quote numerous states
introducing Bible literacy classes
giving students the option of studying
the Bible starting to make a turn back
great and he what he was referring to
most likely is a segment on Fox and
Friends this morning in which a North
Dakota representative is talking about a
bill to add Bible literacy classes to
schools in North Dakota there were
similar bills in Missouri Indiana West
Virginia and Virginia and Florida this
is so good this would be the most
important political reform of my
lifetime better than tax cuts better
than foreign interventions better than
raising spending or lowering spending
this would be so important it's so
important because politics is downstream
of culture and our culture our Western
culture our American culture is
incomprehensible without biblical
literacy of course the cult and the
culture are related etymologically and
the culture is downstream of their
religion what a culture worships it is
jarring to talk to people around the
country and to gauge that they have zero
biblical literacy I you know I read the
texts of other religions long before I
was seriously exposed to reading the
Bible and this I think this is just a
fact of our public education system
right now
even at really look I went to a great
college there it's supposed to be the
cream of the crop students in the
country those students were totally
biblically illiterate almost all of them
what is this really about you know I
tweeted out that this would be the
greatest policy of my lifetime and you
saw a little fissure on the right you
saw some of the libertarian types saying
oh well if you support that would you
support reading the Quran in school
would you support reading the Vedas or
the Bhagavad Gita or this or that would
you support the Quran I'd say well I'd
support reading the Quran in school if
we lived in Saudi Arabia of course
because that culture in that history is
incomprehensible without reading the
Quran I read the Quran before I read the
Bible as a kid I read it because
everyone told me that Islam was the
religion of peace and I didn't believe
it I was pretty skeptical of that so I
read it at age 14 and and of course none
of those people had ever read the Quran
our history our culture our philosophy
our everything that has happened our
literature everything in Western
civilization is incomprehensible if you
don't know the Bible how can you
understand Shakespeare if you haven't
read the Bible how do you catch
references in will everything from
William Faulkner or all the way back to
whomever modern novels how do you
understand any of it without reading the
Bible
William Faulkner are just an example
that popped into my head has a novel
called Absalom Absalom what does that
mean what does that refer to do you know
this audience probably does know because
it's disproportionately biblically
literate Jews and Christians how many
other people in the culture do you think
catch that reference why why wouldn't we
teach Bible literacy we're told it's
because we have a separation of church
and state which is like sort of true we
have no established religion that part
is true but that means that we can't
read the most influential book in the
history of the world think of all the
stupid books that you read in high
school you you can read all of those you
can read Sula you can read all the it's
Howard Zinn whatever all these modern
books but you can't read the most
influential book in the history of the
world well some say well then if
we're teaching the Bible we should teach
all of the religious books we can't we
there isn't enough time education means
you include some things and you exclude
other things this is why I had my high
school teacher on the other day because
he's being targeted by our high school
for his conservative views why is he
being targeted there's a superintendent
in Bedford central school district named
Christopher mono and he doesn't like
that there is one openly conservative
teacher at that school so he's trying to
get that guy fired that guy Christopher
man oh I just found this out the
superintendent who's persecuting my
former teacher when he was a
superintendent in New Jersey he
applauded when students were made by
their teachers to sing hymns to how
great Barack Obama is he defended that
he said oh it's great to do that what a
wonderful educational opportunity
meanwhile you've one conservative
teacher in high school he goes after
them because education requires
including certain things and not other
things it requires analyzing certain
historical periods and not others it
requires reading certain works of
literature and not others and if you're
going to include all of these wonderful
things world history a world literature
this that and the other
shouldn't you include the most important
book ever written that just seems like
common sense
Hillsdale president Larry Oren right now
he just came out and made a statement
that shouldn't be controversial but it
is which is that college is not for
everyone
college is not for everyone for a lot of
people it's a huge waste of money for
some people it's a great thing to do
I love liberal education I fully intend
to send my kids to get a liberal
education that means to major in
something that has no applicability to
anything in the real world to study
literature or history or whatever that's
what a liberal education is liberal
education allows you to make sense of
your freedom to use your free time to
think about grand and eternal questions
and then after that you get some
training to go work a real job in the
real world now some people could go take
stem classes they could they could focus
on not just the liberal arts mathematics
or something but engineering something
really applicable ok that's good some
people should go to trade school and
learn
maybe they don't need to read absalom
absalom maybe they don't you know maybe
they want to learn a trade that's a good
thing maybe some people will go right
into a world of work that's a good thing
maybe they they never really cared about
school they weren't great students if
they go to college they'll just end up a
quarter of a million dollars in debt
instead of learning a trade and then
they can instantly start making money
and being productive and doing something
with their lives maybe some people will
enlist in the military right out of high
school maybe they're really good
athletes maybe they've got a real
patriotic focus maybe they're gonna do
that that's a great thing okay great not
everybody needs to go to some four-year
liberal arts college that's not for
everybody we have now ostensibly the
most educated generation in history oh
all these people going to college so
credentialed and yet they're totally
uneducated standards have been lowered
natural when you flood college with
everybody standards lower it means less
for those people to end because people
in their early education are less
educated now than they were a hundred
years ago because they've never read the
most important book in the history of
the world they haven't read the book
that is essential to understanding all
of the subsequent literature and history
and philosophy and on and on even the
development of Science and Mathematics
all is coming out of the church which
defines our civilization they don't
understand that and there's a further
point because I see some conservatives
making the argument that biblical
literacy is important because you can't
really understand anything else without
it that's true the other reason that
it's important is what all of our really
serious founding fathers talked about
which is that our republic is built for
a moral and religious people so actually
is not just that you learn about it you
know it in some esoteric sense but it's
that what we learn what we engage with
in our culture shapes who we are we're
not just floating brains moving in the
air we have bodies we have actions we
have habits if you read trashy novels
you're gonna think in a certain way
you're gonna behave in a certain way if
you read serious works if you read the
Bible you're going to behave and think
in a different way you will think toward
the verb
you will think in a moral way as
religiosity erodes as a religious
standing understanding erodes or
religious practice erodes as our
religious practice erodes our morals
erode you can't have a moral society
that is not religious as morals erode
discipline erodes that virtue erodes the
sense of purpose in the world and the
sense of purpose for your life erodes
when that happens liberty erodes you
cannot have Liberty without that some
people want to pretend that you can you
really can't you can't govern yourself
if you don't have all of that before you
we want to cut off civilization from the
roots of it it isn't going to work you
become a ridiculous creature like
Kirsten Gillibrand we'll get to a 20/20
update now when I tell you about my
weekend at the commissioning of the USS
Michael Monsoor speaking of virtue and
courage but first we got to think about
Facebook and YouTube if you are on daily
wire.com thank you you help keep the
lights on
you keep qoph fa in my cup if you're not
go over there it's ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the under Clavin sure you get
the Ben Shapiro sure you guys have
questions the mailbag get them at Walsh
oh it does questions backstage you can
get another Kingdom you get so much
stuff and you get this you get the
biblical literacy tumbler you get now
it's not directly related to the Bible
although I'm sure there are many
exegetes who can tell you about the
scriptural significance of the leftist
years tumblr but what will happen is
once these schools start teaching the
most important book in the history of
the world the left they are going to cry
you're going to have maybe a second
flood I know we were told God said he
would never destroy humanity again with
a flood but the left never made that
promise and they might do it so that's
why you need to get your leftist here's
tumblr it's your own personal mini Ark
grab it and we'll be right back with a
lot more
when you're biblically illiterate when
you are uneducated when you are
undisciplined when you can't govern
yourself you become a ridiculous
creature like the future president
future nominee of the Democrat Party
Kirsten Gillibrand we will hold that
shield even when you don't see the whole
staircase
hold on too tightly
we will wield the sword of the Spirit
the sword of the Spirit is the Word of
God and the Good Book promises us the
light shines in the darkness and the
darkness has not overcome the good book
tells us in the beginning was the word
and the Word was with God God God and
the in the word and well the point is
the sword of the Spirit and the pleased
elect me I'm a Christian please really
pathetic display people made fun of
President Trump because he's also not
terribly comfortable speaking in a
religious setting and they made fun of
him for describing 2 Corinthians as 2
Corinthians said oh you're supposed to
say 2nd Corinthians and by the way some
people actually do say 2 Corinthians but
anyway they gave him hell over that they
they constantly go after him as as
incompetent as a religious speaker what
about this Donald Trump is Jonathan
Edwards compared to this lady Donald
Trump is like Jerry Falwell and Billy
Graham and Jonathan Edwards all rolled
up
one are you kidding me it's this Trump
us Fulton sheen compared to kirsten
gillibrand out pathetic is that this is
what happens when you lose a faith
tradition this is what happens you
become a grotesque caricature we help
sad how what what is this what is she
doing
al Sharpton put this video out she's
trying to appeal to two predominantly
black Christian voters in the Democrat
Party it's not really gonna work what
else do we have from the 20/20 update
apparently Kamala Harris had an affair
with a married man 20 years ago
it's another has a little tidbit that
came out of today from the former San
Francisco Mayor Willie Brown Willie
Brown came out and said that he had an
affair with Kamala Harris 20 years ago
and in exchange for that he appointed
her to a couple state Commission's and
launched her entire political career
pretty brutal stuff from this 80
something-year-old former mayor all of
which is to say delicious just just mmm
it is not even February 2019 yet folks
and this is what we're getting out of
the 2020 Democrat primary this is going
to be gold this is going to be so good
Kamala Harris has come out the gate
pretty strong and they are already
attacking her from every angle I mean
they're making her out to be
Hillary 2.0 except she's got no moral
standards she's sleeping with married
men
he's God it's just brutal what they're
doing to her
then kirsten gillibrand is doing it to
herself and then you've got Howard
Schultz who is the CEO of Starbucks
coming out and saying that he's going to
run an independent bid and spoil it for
whoever the ultimate Democrat nominee is
anyway I am seriously thinking of
running for president I will run as a
centrist independent outside of the
two-party system we're living at a most
fragile time not only the fact that this
president is not qualified to be the
president but the fact that both parties
are consistently not doing what's
necessary on behalf of the American
people and aren't engaged every single
day in revenge politics why run as an
end
pendant your views have always aligned
with the Democratic Party it's true I've
you know I've been a lifelong Democrat I
look at both parties we see extremes on
both sides well we are sitting today
with approximately 21 and a half
trillion dollars of debt which is a
reckless example not only of Republicans
but of Democrats as well as a reckless
failure of their constitutional
responsibility run Howard run run Howard
run Howard Schultz is a far left to
Democrat he's the guy who turns
Starbucks into a homeless shelter he is
the one who's installing heroin needles
into the Starbucks bathrooms he is just
a real hippie dippie leftist guy and he
might run in an independent bid he knows
he's not gonna win the Democrat primary
there's no way a straight white
billionaire man is ever gonna win that
primary won't get one vote in it but he
would he would be able to get a good
number of votes as an independent
because you've got a sizable number of
Democrats or these days probably former
Democrats who were so turned off by
intersectional nasty identity politics
and you've got those same people who
don't really like Donald Trump because
he's too right-wing or he's too vulgar
or whatever Howard Schultz would appear
would appeal to them and Donald Trump
knows it and he's encouraging him to run
he tweeted out today that Howard Schultz
doesn't have the guts to run for
president and he's doing it with all the
subtlety of Donald Trump he's saying
this because if Schultz ran as an
independent it would all but ensure a
Trump reelection so what I am Telling
You hear me closely take notes if you're
driving pull over every one of you has
to write a letter to Howard Schultz
begging him to run for president right
at send it to Starbucks
tweet Adams send him an email we need to
get this guy to run as an independent it
would be phenomenal it oh oh the joys he
has been signaling that he wants to run
for a while so I think he's probably in
it and it'll just be a singular joy if
they can get him
it's going to become the 2000 election
all over again
this is my other observation even this
early on do you remember the 2000
election I was such a political hound
that I've been following politics since
really since I was 2 years old and I
remember in the 2000 election I was
about 10 years old and it struck me that
that election was about nothing
what was that election about what was
the big issue nothing the election was
about how Bill Clinton's a degenerate
and the economy was going pretty well
and everything was basically fine 9/11
hadn't happened yet it was just about
nothing got all of these candidates and
you had third parties making a push in
92 Ross Perot ran as the Reform Party
candidate he spoiled it for George Bush
George Bush lost the election Bill
Clinton became president in 2000 Donald
Trump almost ran for president as the
Reform Party candidate he was running
for the Reform Party nomination against
Pat Buchanan Pat Buchanan then is
running in the 2000 election takes a lot
of votes away Ralph Nader was another
one a spoiler who probably threw the
election to George Bush this is deja vu
all over again I can't wait to have an
election about nothing because elections
about nothing just become about people
and all this stupid fighting and for
years now we've been told how terrible
person Donald Trump is everybody else is
so pure so wonderful all those
sanctimonious pseudo conservatives all
the way to the crazy virtue signaling
leftists they're also morally pure and
good and only Donald Trump is bad we're
about to find out what degeneres all
these people are we're about to find out
that Kamala Harris had an affair with a
married man 20 years ago and did it so
that she could just advance her career
pretty cynical move we're about to find
out a lot of things about a lot of these
people I can't wait that'll be a lot of
fun it's not just the schadenfreude that
I'm looking forward to it's not just
having delicious tears at their expense
and drinking up their misery it's
because they need to be taken down a peg
they are so sanctimonious they are so
prideful and they're about to find out
the wages of that another shock
News the government reopened did I
forget to mention that yeah the
government reopened all right whatever
okay is during this shutdown I said okay
the government shut the is it shutdown
does anyone know is it and now it's open
and I all right whatever
I guess Trump sort of gave in maybe
it'll close again in three weeks and
whatever what it does bring up to me
though is that this immigration debate
is about a lot more than a border wall
we're all talking about it is the border
wall we're all talking about it just as
a matter of illegal immigration it's
actually about more than that and of all
people the left-wing former anchor of
NBC News Tom Brokaw is making this clear
he he fits in a true statement in
between a bunch of kind of leftist
claptrap about how Republicans are
racist but he actually gets a true
statement in there as well about
assimilation we don't want to talk about
what the fact is on the Republican side
a lot of people see the rise of our
extraordinary important new constituent
in American politics Hispanics who will
come here and all be Democrats
also I hear when I push people a little
hard oh I don't know whether I want
brown grandbabies I mean that's also a
part of it it's the intermarriage that
is going on or the cultures that are
conflicting with each other I also
happen to believe that the Hispanics
should work harder at assimilation
that's one of the things I've been
saying for a long time you know they
ought not to be just codified in their
communities but make sure that all their
kids are learning to speak English and
that they feel comfortable in the
communities and that's gonna take
outreach on both sides frankly now of
course this last thing that he makes
this last point that he makes is true
Hispanics need to assimilate into
American culture it's not just their
fault that they're not assimilating at
the same speed at which other immigrant
groups have done it a lot of it is
thanks to the culture which discourages
them from assimilating which tells them
to keep speaking Spanish which tells
them that America is awful and the West
is a terrible place why they would want
to come here I have no idea why we would
take in over a million people a year I
can't imagine if we're such a terrible
place but that point is right the point
about Republicans don't want brown
grandbabies that's just typical leftist
NBC nonsense but the point is making
about us
simulation is fair I think and that's
not just illegal immigration that that
has to do with that's legal immigration
there is a big poll that came out I
think from Harvard Harris which showed
that the majority of Americans don't
just want less illegal immigration they
want less legal immigration and they
don't just want less legal immigration
they want radically less legal
immigration right now we're about 1.2
million a year they want that down to
about half a million and why is that
well one that's a million people a year
is a lot of people to absorb into a
country constantly coming in but I think
we could absorb it if we encouraged
assimilation but I think a lot of people
really hate pressing one for English and
I think they're totally justified in
doing that and it's wrong for the
immigrants it's wrong to encourage them
not to learn English so that they're a
permanent second-class so that certain
jobs just are cut off from them that
certain educational opportunities just
are cut off from them you have to
assimilate when my great-grandfather
came to America from Italy
he was basically ashamed of being
Italian and he was rightly ashamed of
being Italian because he's in America
and he has to learn English so he would
read the newspaper in English all the
time he wouldn't speak Italian really in
the home he felt that he had left a
culture for good reason and he was
coming to a new culture and he was going
to succeed at that new culture that is a
radically different attitude than what
the left tells us to do today which is
that we should assimilate to immigrants
we certainly should not do that that's
crazy and it creates a bad situation not
just for the country but for the
immigrants as well a really interesting
point at the end there by Tom Brokaw of
course he's had to walk it back now
because they left pounced on him and a
conservative hasn't watched at NBC News
in 30 years
this ties into some other aspects of
this debate which will just have to get
to tomorrow because I want to point out
before I leave I had the honor this
weekend of attending the commissioning
of the USS Michael Monsoor down at
Coronado this is a zumwalt-class ship
it's a destroyer it looks like it's
something out of Star Wars it is a
really cool ship it's been in the
process of being built now for over 20
years and being designed and being
thought of and so this was the last step
on the way for the Michael Monsoor and
it was commissioned on Saturday
the Michael Monsoor was named after
Michael Monsoor who's a Navy SEAL who
was killed in Ramadi in action in 2006 I
believe and him a young man really young
man 24 25 years old and I bring this up
because it's an unbelievably inspiring
story as a national hero he previously
had been there a teammate of his had
been shot in the street wide open and he
ran out with a heavy machine gun was
shooting at the bad guys how a hundred
pounds on his back and still managed to
drag this guy his teammate to safety and
that teammate of his had a vision as he
was going in and out of consciousness of
an angel and Michael Monsoor was a
devout Catholic who went to daily Mass
he went to even when he was in theater
he would go to daily Mass he was named
after Saint Michael the Archangel who is
the defender of warriors there's the
prayer at the end of every Mass Saint
Michael the Archangel defend us in
battle be our defense against the
wickedness and snares of the devil and
the crest of this ship includes wing and
a sword from Saint Michael he was killed
in action when he was on a rooftop and
he was there were enemy combatants who
came up and someone hurled a grenade at
him and it bounced off of his chest and
Michael Monsoor saw the grenade there
and he could have lunged to safety he
was apparently near a doorway but his
teammates and the Iraqi soldiers who
were with them were cut off and they
almost certainly would have been killed
and you're talking about a split-second
decision the grenade bounced off him
landed in front of him and he screamed
grenade and he jumped on the grenade and
everyone else survived and he did not
and he gave his life for his friends and
for his teammates and for his country
coincidentally on the feast day of st.
Michael Michael Monsoor clearly had a
sense of purpose and a sense of virtue
and honor but purpose Providence what
are the odds what are the odds
that that would happen on the feast day
of st. Michael devout Catholic named
after Michael the Archangel what are the
odds well in a world that has purpose in
a world in which all nature is but art
unknown to thee and all chance Direction
which thou canst not see it happens all
the time
and we're talking today about biblical
literacy about virtue about honor in all
of those speeches at the commissioning
of the USS Michael Monsoor everything
was appropriate
everything was serious everything was
about honor and virtue and goodness
patriotism and when you look around the
culture today you don't see a whole lot
of that you see people whining about
microaggressions you see a quarter of
college students having PTSD because
their preferred political candidate
didn't win the presidential election in
2016 that's because they don't have a
sense of virtue a sense of purpose a
sense of moral reality and a sense of
Providence Michael Monsoor had it he's a
an unbelievable inspiration to the
entire country the USS Michael Monsoor
will now sail for hopefully 4045 years
and we wish them fair winds and
following seas that's our show come back
tomorrow we've got a lot more to talk
about in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael doles show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
Audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick Sheehan hair and makeup
is by Jessa
Vera the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19